Я - Тарас Тополя, лідер гурту "Антитіла", батько трьох дітей.
Мене звати Ірина Цибух, я - парамедик добровольчого батальйону "Госпітальєри".
Мене звати Ахтем Сеітаблаєв, я - режисер, актор, директор ДП "Кримський дім".
Мій позивний - Кудрява, і я - військовослужбовиця найкращої бригади швидкого реагування Національної гвардії України.
Мене звати Жорін Максим, я захищаю країну з 2014 року.
Мій позивний - Яра, я - військова морської піхоти.
На війні ми опинилися в перший день.
Коли почалася повномасштабна війна у мене не було іншого уявлення про те,
як я можу допомогти, аніж бути медиком на передовій.
Питання не стояло: йти чи не йти.
Після першої гарячої фази війни 2014-2015 року, дуже добре розуміла, що Росія повторить наступ.
Завжди чітко знав, що я маю бути там, де я маю захищати свою батьківщину, своїх близьких, свою націю.
Я тут на війні, тому що я кадрова військова, тому що це мій вибір і моє покликання.
За останні пів року Україна отримала величезну кількість ран, які бдуть ще довго загоюватися.
Дуже щиро сподіваюся, що кожен усвідомлює, хто насправді наш брат і друг.
Багато хто прийняв, що війна - це наша доля, і якщо ми хочемо існувати, ми повинні боротися за себе,
повинні вміти захищати себе і повинні вміти солідаризуватися.
Єдине, в чому війна нас не змінила - це в наших цінностях,
в нашому прагненні свободи, незалежного і вільного майбутнього.
Через 10 років хотів би бачити сильну, сучасну, цивілізовану європейську країну…
З поверненим Кримом, Донецьком, Луганськом та пам'яттю про усіх полеглих, полонених...
Щоб в країні було верховенство права.
Щоб у наших батьків була гідна старість.
Сильно хочеться жити ось це своє класне цивільне життя, їздити на Сицилію,
пити вино на Подолі, зустрічатися з друзями…
Я сумую за цим життям і сподіваюся, що ще вдасться повернутися…
Через 10 років, я впевнений, що наші діти продовжать те, що почали ми…
Я дуже хочу після перемоги передати нашу Україну нашим дітям і онукам в кращому стані, ніж її залишили нам.
Всім цивільним, які сьогодні почали відчувати втому, невпевненість, слабкість, або навіть падати духом,
я би порадив - подивіться на українських військових.
Пригадайте, як героїчно захищали Маріуполь.
Коли опускаються руки, коли стає дуже складно, дозвольте собі відпочити.
Але потім, з новими силами, робіть все, що можете, з тим, що маєте.
Вірте в ЗСУ, в Національну гвардію, Військово-морські сили України...
Кожен з нас має потенціал боротися за свою країну, тому що наша країна дуже нам важить.
Вона для нас є основою, бо нащо жити будь-яке життя, якщо немає куди повернутися і немає де його жити.
Я не хочу вас обманювати - легше найближчим часом не буде. Але я точно знаю, що ми вистоїмо.
Я пам'ятаю, півроку тому в березні, в кінці лютого біля Маріуполя було дуже холодно.
Холод, який врізався в шкіру, приростав до неї. Були миті, коли я сумнівалася,
що ми і наша держава доживе до 24 серпня, до дня незалежності, але ось, ми дожили.
Я хочу привітати всіх українців з Днем незалежності.
Це сьогодні не просто слова, не просто дати, не просто свято.
Сьогодні саме незалежність - це символ того, заради чого щодня ми боремося і проливаємо кров.
Я би хотіла попросити всіх українців жити своє найкраще життя. Бо воно в нас одне.
Легенди і міфи пишуться і створюються прямо зараз в Україні.
І ми з моєю коханою якраз бажаємо вам і кохання в першу чергу, тому що це надзвичайно мотивує.
З Днем незалежності, Україно! Ми переможемо, бо ми вже перемогли, тому що ми не зламалися і ми боремося.
З днем незалежності, і пам'ятайте, якою ціною вона нам дається.
Будьмо сильними і йдемо до перемоги. З днем незалежності!
Мирного неба, бережіть себе, слава Україні!
Героям слава!